There’s this piece from search for the Holy
Grail. And the Holy Grail is a myth that was
constructed in England. And-And the myth goes
something like this:
There is a-- There is a cup, the Grail, used
to hold Christ’s blood. And that cup has
a-- has redemptive significance and it’s
been lost.
And the knights – King Arthur’s knights
– who go off to look for the Holy Grail
are after this cup. So, it’s a redemption
story, right?
It means, the world’s damned, unredeemed.
There’s some object that can serve as, as
the source of redemption – the source of
nourishment, say, thinking about it from a
symbolic perspective – and it’s worthwhile
to go on a quest of that sort.
And the King Arthur story is set up in an
interesting way, ‘cause there’s a king,
Arthur, but he has all these knights, these
nobles, and they all sit at a round table.
And they’re at a round table because they’re
equals. So, although it’s a hierarchical
story, there’s-there’s a motif in it that
transcends the hierarchy.
It says: Well… yeah, under normal circumstances
everyone’s arranged in a hierarchy. But
when you’re out to seek whatever you need,
then everyone’s an equal. And so, fine,
so they sit at the round table, and then they
go off to search for the Holy Grail
And the story opens with a very interesting
motif, which is the knights look at the forest
and then they try to find the part that looks
the darkest, to them. And then, they go that
way. That’s the marker for their mission,
right, to go to the darkest place. And of
course, each knight goes off in a different
direction because the world looks slightly
different to each knight.
So… objectively speaking, they’re going
to a different place. But psychologically
speaking, they are going to the same place,
right? And that place, I suppose, is being
represented in mythology and literature as
“The Heart of Darkness”.
And if you were ever curious about why people
aren’t enlightened – since it seems to
be a possibility – you can always think
about the story of King Arthur and the knights
of the Holy Grail, and think: Well, do you
really want to enter the forest at the darkest
place? And the answer to that is of course:
No, because the darkest place means precisely
that place you least want to go. And it’s
the same for everyone
So then, I have this little nephew, although
he’s almost 15 now. He had this dream when
he was four years old. And the background
to the dream is this: He was waking up in
the middle of the night for months, screaming.
He had night terrors. And this went on for
like six months. And what was happening in
his life was twofold: There was some instability
in his family, ‘cause his parents got divorced
about a year after that. And also, he was
at the transition point from staying at home
to going to kindergarten.
So, you know, not only was he making the big
move out there into the terrible world, but
the stable point from which he might like
to have moved was shaky. So, you know, he
wasn’t having that great a time.
so anyways he’s screaming away at night,
and this is pretty unsettling, right, ‘cause
night terrors are no joke, and so he’s upset
about it, and his mom’s upset about it,
and so I’m watching him and he’s running
around the house; he’s only about this high,
a very verbal kid, and he’s got this knight
hat on, and this sword and this shield, and
he’s running around the house being a knight,
and at night he takes his night hat and his
shield and his sword to bed,
and I think, we’ll that’s pretty cool,
and you can see how that makes sense, right,
and you can see how it’s an enacted reality
‘cause children enact or act out their reality
before they can explicitly understand it,
just like we do, and so I’m staying there,
he wakes up, and he has, you know, one of
these fits, and then the next morning he comes
to breakfast, and I said, hey, did you have
any dreams last night, and he goes, yeah,
I had a dream; I said, well, tell us the dream,
and there’s six adults sitting around the
table and, you know, we’re ready for this
dream, or so we think, and then he says, okay,
I was out in this field and I was surrounded
by beaked dwarfs, and they came up to my knees,
and so these dwarfs they had no arms, they
just had shoulders, and powerful legs, and
they had, they were all covered with hair,
and they had a cross shaved on the top of
their head, and they were all covered with
grease, and everywhere I went these dwarfs
would jump up with their beaks and bite me,
and you’re looking at him like, that accounts
for the night terrors, right,
and so then he says, yeah, and there’s more
to it too; if, if you look in the background
behind all the dwarfs there was a dragon way
in the background and it was puffing out fire
and smoke, and every time it puffed out fire
and smoke, a whole bunch more of these dwarfs
would get made, and you think, that’s pretty
cool, that’s a hydra story, right, remember
the story of the hydra, cut off one head,
two more grows, it’s one of Hercules’
trials, and that’s an observation about
the world, which is, you solve one problem,
and like two more problems pop up, and then
you solve those and…
Anyways, he says, okay, well I’ve got this
dragon back there, and so this is his problem,
right, he’s been eaten by beaked dwarfs,
and that’s not good, and there’s not much
sense fighting them off because there’s
just more of them made every time this thing
lurking in the background breathes, so I said,
what could you do about that
it’s like his brain was working all these
ideas around and he’d heard lots of Disney
stories and had lots of books read to him,
and had abstracted out a lot of information,
but he hadn’t quite got it right, and it
was all seething around in his head, and I
just said, well, what could you do, tap, and
he went, oh I know what I could do.
I could take my sword and I’d get my dad,
which is a good notion, right, ‘cause he’s
small, and then I’d jump up on the dragon
and I’d pop out both of its eyes with the
sword so it couldn’t see me, and then I’d
go down its throat to the box where the fire
came out, and then I’d carve a piece out
of the box and I’d use that as a shield,
and I thought, great, you really got the story,
and the story’s something like this,
right: If you’re being plagued by midget
dwarfs and you wipe them out and they keep
multiplying, well you’re obviously aiming
at the wrong target, right, you should be
going to their source, so he went after the
dragon, but not only after the dragon, he
went right down the throat of the dragon,
which is, you know, a fairly brave thing to
do, and then right to the place where the
fire, the transforming element, was being
produced, and he took a piece of the device
that made the transforming element, and he
used it as a shield.
Okay. Well that’s really cool, and the story’s
better than that, I think, and it’s true
even, so it’s not one of those fake, he-was-dreaming-and-then-woke-up
sort of stories; this actually happened; he
didn’t have any more nightmares,
so when I checked with his mother, repeatedly
after that because I thought, well this is
too good to be true, right, he’s got this
terrible night terror thing, he does one little
mythological dream thing, and, bang, he’s,
he’s better,
but that’s the case, it is the case, he
didn’t have any more nightmares after that,
and I think that’s because he’d almost
already got it, right; he was running around
like a knight; he knew, almost, it just had
to be made a little more explicit, and not
even that explicit ‘cause it was still a
story. he didn’t know you should go to the
source of your anxieties, right, to the thing
that plagues you the most, and you should
explore that in detail until you find the
information that it contains that will protect
you against it.
He couldn’t say that, but he could tell
the story, and he could act it out, and that
looked like it was good enough, so that’s
pretty cool, so he basically, you know, he
managed this, essentially, he fought the dragon
of chaos, popped back up, as what, as he who
can obtain victory over the dragon of chaos,
and that’s a pretty good story because it
says, well, if your frame of reference gets
blown away by something you don’t understand,
some new challenge, and you face the challenge,
at least courageously and, and humbly, which
means, you know, you’re not gonna run away,
and you still have something to learn, then
you can extract something out of the battle
that will enable you to withstand it.
and you think, well why should I believe that,
right, and the answer to that would be, well,
don’t knock it till you try it, and the
second answer would be, that’s exactly what
we do in clinical psychotherapy all the time,
and there’s endless amounts, I think, of
empirical evidence saying that, you bring
someone in, they’ve got an anxiety disorder,
maybe they’re even depressed, whatever,
they’re running away. You say, you actually
don’t have to run away;
here’s what you have to do: you have to
break the problem down into little pieces,
digestible pieces, and then you have to hit
it one by one, and what you’ll discover
is, not that you habituate to the anxiety
because that’s a silly theory; instead what
you discover is that you thought you were
the person who had to run away, but it turns
out you’re not the person who has to run
away, you’re the person that can stand there
while you’re anxious and learn something,
and what you most particularly learn is that
you’re the person who can stand there when
they’re anxious and learn, and if you’ve
learned that, you don’t have to be anxious
anymore, or even more importantly, if you’re
anxious, it doesn’t matter, it doesn’t
mean your life’s over, it just means that
there you are on the threshold, right, between
what you know and what you don’t know, and
you have something to learn, and you can learn
it,
and I think that’s what the empirical evidence
suggests too because you got Edna Foa’s
work with post-traumatic stress disorder victims,
primarily women who were violently raped,
and Foa says, well I know you don’t like
to think about the event, and it’s no bloody
wonder, look what it did to you, and how terrible
it was, but if you re-live it over and over
and over again in your imagination, in as
much detail as possible, including all the
motivational and emotional details, which
she measures psycho-physiologically, you will
get better faster and you will stay better
longer, and her work’s well documented,
and then there’s endless cases of exposure
in psychotherapy, you can certainly eliminate
simple phobias within an hour, and even complex
phobias like agoraphobia, which is more like
fear of everything. It’s not an intractable
disorder
Imagine that throughout your whole life you
never turned away from a mistake, not even
once, never. So that whenever you made a mistake
that you could rectify, you did rectify it.
Then the question would be well, what, what
exactly would you be like? Would you be suffering
from all your existential trouble? Would you
be vulnerable to anxiety? What would you be
like?
And then I think well I only know a couple
of stories like that. And the one that I told
you is the story of Solzhenitsyn. Because
Solzhenitsyn, a Russian novelist sitting in
the concentration camps in the Gulag archipelago
thinking, starving, this isn't so good. How
in the world did I get here? And the simple
story is well Stalin put you there and he
was bad, right? End of story. It's not your
problem. Stalin's problem. But Solzhenitsyn
said well, that doesn't really leave me anything
to do right, to construe myself as a simple
victim of fate? And I do have a lot of time
on my hands since I'm not really doing anything
that requires a tremendous amount of intellectual
effort. Let's try a game. Let's do this. Let's
pretend that the reason that things happen
to me that I don't like even terrible things
say, or that I can't tolerate, is not because
I'm a victim of fate, evil cruel fate, but
because there’s something I didn't do.
And so Solzhenitsyn said well, I'm gonna go
back over my whole life, right? Step by step,
detail by detail. And I’m gonna try to remember
every time I let something go or I didn't
do something I was supposed to. Not because
of some adherence to some you know, arbitrary
moral code, cause we don't believe in those
anyways, right? But just because I noted that
I can tell when I owe a debt to existence,
right?
So then you look at Solzhenitsyn and he says
okay, well so I spent fifteen years trying
to untie all the knots that I tied up in my
brain. And the consequence was, of that was
first I started to notice there are some people
out there I really admired, man. They were
so tough it was unbelievable. You put them
in the worst circumstances and they didn't
bend an inch. They were tough. And even the
nastiest prison guards in the... well, they
could kill them, that's for sure. But they
couldn't bend them. And they couldn't break
them. And I really learned something from
that, right? And it's a good story. Because
he's in the worst possible circumstance. So
there's kind of no bottom past that. You don't
get much worse than the Gulag prison camp,
right? That’s, it’s cold. You don't get
anything to eat and you’re being worked
to death, right? For something pointless.
And to serve Stalin. That's, that's the bottom.
And he said even under those circumstances
there were still people who could, who could
thrive, who could manifest admirable qualities.
He said once I figured out I was wrong, I
could actually find them and learn from them.
Then he wrote this book, which you know about,
the Gulag Archipelago, which was released
in the west and then circulated all through
the Soviet Union. And was undoubtedly one
of the factors that contributed to the demise
of the Soviet Union. And so then you think
well that's pretty interesting, isn't it?
You got this one wacko, right? Russian prisoner,
starving to death. Tattooed. He says maybe
I had something to do with this. But he didn't
mean it in some casual sort of, maybe I had
something to do with this way. He meant geez,
this is really awful. Doesn't get much worse.
Maybe it's my fault. You know, I don't know
how it could be. But it, after all I'm the
one that's suffering. So, maybe it was me.
Maybe I could fix it. What would happen if
I did?
And so his conclusion was at the end. And
it's not a conclusion that he reached alone,
was one person who stops lying can bring down
a tyranny. And you think that’s a metaphorical
statement, right? Because you're the victim
of your own tyrannies, just as you are the
victim of someone else's tyrannies. And maybe
if you stop lying, construed in this manner
of sin of omission, right? Don't avoid anomalies
anymore. But confront them head on. Maybe
if you quit lying, well then you wouldn't
be victim of tyranny. Maybe no one else would
be either.
The G.R.E. say, the bad exam, that’s a bad
thing, but it’s not the worst thing;
the worst thing is the sort of thing that
knocks existentialists for a loop, right,
the worst thing is more like Ivan Karamazov’s
suffering of innocent children, right, the
fact that children are tortured, or the worst
thing is the fact that perfectly good people
get sick and die, and sometimes painfully,
or the worst thing is there are tyrants all
over the world and they torture people for
no cause or maybe even just because they like
torturing people, and that’s an anomaly
of a different order, right,
it’s not just that you’re going from Point
A to B and something you don’t like happens,
it’s more like thee are some aspects of
existence that look so terrible in and of
themselves associated with our vulnerability
that just apprehending them might be enough
to knock the bottom out of your faith in any
frame of reference,
and that’s a kind of Nietzschean theme,
Nietzsche says: look, when you’re going
from Point A to B and something bad happens,
something you don’t expect, you don’t
get to where you wanted to go, that’s bad,
but what’s even worse is, you can’t have
any faith in the frame of reference that you
were using, ‘cause it’s been invalidated,
but what’s even worst is, you plow your
way through two or three frames of reference,
and then you start to develop some skepticism
about frames of reference in general, right.
so I was a socialist, say, and then I was
a Catholic, and, you know then I developed
some new age philosophy, and none of those
really worked, and what that made me think
was, well you can’t trust socialism, you
can’t trust Christianity, and those new
age people are certainly out to lunch, maybe
you can’t trust any frames of reference,
and that’s a really devastating discovery,
and Nietzsche associated that with the death
of God, right, it’s like, no frames of reference
work, and then you have the problem that,
well, without a frame of reference life is
chaos, and chaos is intolerable, and therefore
logically life is intolerable,
and I tried to make a case for you then that’s
kind of a side case, which was, people protect
their ideologies ‘cause they don’t want
to lose their frames of reference, they don’t
want to fall into chaos, but then there’s
this additional problem, which is that you
can develop a kind of deep cynicism about
life in a secondary manner, which is like
constant loss of faith.
maybe what you conclude under those conditions,
like the aggressive child concludes, is that,
fundamentally, I’m not to be trusted, you’re
not to be trusted, society is not to be trusted,
and maybe the structure of the world as a
whole isn’t to be trusted, and, therefore,
logically, you’re more or less obligated
to work against it,
and so then you have a nice sub-story for
the propagation of evil, which is, well, we
like to have our ideological frames of reference
retained, and that gives us ample reason to
squash anyone that’s different, but then
there’s this additional reason, which is,
when you get right down to it, things are
pretty, bloody awful, and maybe the sensible
thing to do is to just work for the in annihilation
of things, and I think we’ve had endless
examples of people who did precisely that
in the 20th Century and almost got away with
it,
in case you’re tempted not to take this
sufficiently seriously, right, we know that
Stalin, in all likelihood,, who I think you
could make a case for being if not the most
evil man that ever lived, certainly the most
evil man that lived this century, and that’s
really a high honor, right, ‘cause he was
up against some really top contenders.
We know, as a consequence of recently-released
KGB documents, that he was probably gearing
up to start the Third World War, and not one
of these little half-rate, you know, little
local Third World Wars, we are talking about
the whole H bomb exchange thing designed to
eradicate, you know, the U.S. for sure, but
also the Soviet Union,
and, well, mere territoriality isn’t enough
to account for that, but then maybe you can
see Stalin’s point, right, like Tolstoy
can see it, you know, if life is really so
awful at bottom, which there are perspectives
from which that certainly seems to be the
case, then why bother having it around at
all.
Well, you know, that’s a pretty dismal perspective,
so that’s a real anomaly, right, that’s
not one of these little second-rate you’ll-get-over-it-in-a-month-or-two
anomalies,
this is the sort of anomaly that’s laid
out in Genesis, where Adam and Eve discover
that they’re mortal, vulnerable, they’re
gonna die, that really takes the shine off
existence out of paradise they go, they wander
around the planet for the rest of history,
you know, working themselves to death and
being miserable and killing each other, and
that’s basically the story that’s laid
out in the Old Testament, and viewed from
that perspective, well, it’s not precisely
an empirical description of the big bang say,
but it’s not a bad description of the nature
of human existence, and it’s pretty dismal
There’s an essential symbolic relationship
between the ingestion of food and its transformative
capacities and the, and the ingestion of ideas,
and their transformative capacity.
and what happens when Adam and Eve eat this
fruit, which they’re not supposed to eat,
is that they learn that they’re going to
die, and that screws up Paradise,
and in case you just think I’m making this
up, which would be, you know, kind of annoying,
then you want to look at this picture, which
is from the 14th Century, and it’s a really
remarkable picture, so what you’ve got in
the middle here is the, the tree of the fruit
of the knowledge of good and evil, and you’ve
got Eve over here, and you’ve got the Church
here, and what you see happening, you got
to look really carefully at this tree ‘cause
the first thing you see is it’s got this
snake wrapped around it, this agent of transformation,
right, who’s associated with Satan, and
then up in the branches you have apples and
you have skulls, and then if you look at Eve
here, she’s got grapes here, and a skull
in her hand, and what this artist is trying
to indicate is that there’s this tight relationship
between Eve tempting Adam towards higher knowledge
and delivering him death.
so that’s a pretty dismal story, and all
the people over here on the left side, all
these unhappy people, are the people who are
living in chaos and misery as a consequence
of being, of having their vulnerability revealed
to them, and that’s the negative side of
the story,
but then there’s the positive side of the
story over here, and it’s, it’s just as
complicated, and that’s partly why it’s
expressed in imagistic form,
so you’ve got the Church here, symbolized
at least in part as Mary, and she’s handing
out something too, and if you look at those
they’re little round circles with crosses
on them, and what those are, are hosts, hosts,
they’re the symbols of transformation, particularly
in Catholicism; now that’s a very complicated
idea, and this is the idea, it’s something
like this:
At Christ’s last supper before he was crucified,
he told his disciples that they were going
to have to ingest him, right, so they gave
them wine and bread, and the wine was blood
and the bread was flesh, and what’s the
idea, what does it mean to incorporate someone?
It means to embody them, that’s what it
means, and this, this imagistic ritualistic
process, is the notion that in order to attain
redemption, it’s necessary to embody the
hero, and that’s kind of what this picture
is trying to portray,
it says, okay, well you got this death apple
over on the left-hand side, and that’s not
so good, and you need an antidote to it, and
the antidote is whatever this represents,
whatever this represents, and you see up in
the tree here there’s all these hosts hanging.
Now the hosts are representative of Christ,
and for complicated reasons they’re made
out of wheat, say, and partly the reason they’re
made out of wheat is because if you look at
hero Gods prior to Christianity, you see that
wheat was often conceptualized as a dying
and redeemed God, right, because it would
die in the Winter and then be re-born in the
Spring, just like all plants are, and the
notion of the dying and redeeming, the dying
and resurrecting hero, was kind of, what would
you say, layered on top of that older agrarian
idea, and all mixed together, and it sort
of popped out in this idea of the, of the
host,
and so the idea here is that whatever ails
human beings, which is their knowledge of
vulnerability and death, can be rectified
by their incorporation of whatever this symbol
represents,
and so then you might ask, well what exactly
does that symbol represent, and, of course,
the standard Christian answers to that, and
the extended Christian answers are, well it
represents your faith in Christ, say, but
that’s not a very useful answer, all things
considered, so let’s look at it in a little
bit more complicated way.
It’s not a useful answer I think because
it’s too sectarian, right, it excludes many,
many people, this notion, and there’s a
whole formalism that you have to buy into
to even get access to what that story means,
and it’s an unfortunate formalism because
first of all I think it’s more appropriate
to an earlier time and place, and second of
all because I think we’re actually sophisticated
enough now intellectually, psychologically,
to actually start to understand what some
of these stories mean,
and since we have reasonably well-developed
brains, and we might as well use them, it
would be better if they were on our side,
so to speak, than constantly conspiring to
undermine our faith,
let's look at what a person is like. And a
person is sort of just as complicated as a,
an object, which is not that surprising cause
there's an aspect of us that is object like,
right? Our objective being.
And we know people are unbelievably complicated.
They have they have nervous systems that have
more connections in them than there are subatomic
particles in the universe, just for starters.
And so that means that when you're looking
at another person, you're looking at something
that's more complicated than anything else
that exists anywhere, including the sum total
of everything that exists everywhere, except
other people. More complex than everything.
And then you have to understand too that just
because you don't think of yourself that way
doesn’t mean you're not that way.
It just means that you're conscious mind,
your rational mind say isn't sophisticated
enough to actually completely model who or
what you are. And that's obvious because that's
why we study ourselves. We don't know who
we are. We're trying to figure it out. We've
been trying to figure it out ever since we
woke some thousands of years ago. We don't
know when
And you think well if you look at people,
well you know, there's the kind of obvious
level that you see people at, the self level,
which is the privileged level of analysis
for the west. But you’re a member of a family.
And if I said well are you more yourself or
your family, you might say well, most of the
time I think I'm more myself, but I might
be willing to sacrifice my life for my child's.
In which case I would say well, then you’re
just as much your child as you are you. Or
maybe you’re even more your child. And what
about your family? Well that's a tough question
too. And then what about your cultural group?
Well you say no, it's me, not my cultural
group. But then I'd say well what if there's
a war? Is it you or your cultural group? And
then you’ll say oh it's my cultural group.
And then you see as well, well at this level
of analysis are you your biological group?
Is that what you identify with, the biosphere
say? Say well no, not generally. But there's
a lot of environmentalists out there. And
they say well what we should primarily be
concerned with is the global health of the
planet because our survival depends on that.
We're as much that as we are the self. And
you might not agree with that. And I suspect
that most of the time there's screwy reasons
for proposing such a thing. But on the other
hand, a case can be made.
I mean we know that you can undermine your
ecosystems. It happened in Spain. They let,
four hundred years ago they let the sheep
eat everything. And so Spain turned into a
desert. Doesn't seem like a particularly wise
move.
And then you think well below the phenomenological
level there's all these sub elements of you,
your physiological structure, your cellular
structure, your atomic structure. To infinite
investigation. Absolutely complex. You'll
never exhaust it if you investigate it. And
it's perfectly reasonable to presuppose that
you're all these things
How does it change the world if you stop thinking
about it as made of objects? But, but instead
made of your own experience. And how does
it change the world if you think you have
an ethical relationship with that experience
that, that's a primary fact, not some secondary
derivative. So primary a fact that you can't
even look at the world except through an ethical
lens, primary fact. What is, how does that
change the way you conceptualize yourself
in relationship to the world? I don't know.